Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Alice: 我误打误撞竟然发现了切皮蛋的妙招
Alice: I accidentally discovered a trick to cut century eggs.
Alice: 那就是把它冷冻起来
Alice: Just freeze them.
Alice: 好的不是妙招切不动
Alice: Well, it's not a trick. They can't be cut.
Alice: 比我的命都硬
Alice: They're harder than my life.
Alice: 但是他不会乱溜
Alice: But they won't slip around.
Katrina:  你知道我现在看你干所有的事情
Katrina: You know, everything you do now,
Katrina:  都觉得很神奇
Katrina: seems amazing to me.
Katrina:  因为我妈也不会做
Katrina: Because even my mom can't do it.
Katrina:  这种我从来没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this before.
Katrina:  有种非常崇拜的感觉
Katrina: I feel so admiring.
Tasha: 把他们搅合到完全融合的状态
Tasha: Mix them until they are completely blended.
Tasha: 就是你既看不出来他像他
Tasha: So you can't tell which is which.
Tasha: 你看他现
Tasha: Look, now,
Tasha: 在就是还有油花在那个最边边
Tasha: there are still some oil spots on the edges.
Tasha: 嗯所以就还没有融合
Tasha: So it's not fully blended yet.
Tasha: 差不多就可以了吧
Tasha: Almost done, I guess.
Tasha: 可以再搅一下
Tasha: You can stir it a bit more.
Tasha: 我去拿下一个材料
Tasha: I'll get the next ingredient.
Tasha: 哈哈哈可以
Tasha: Haha, that's good.
Tasha: 然后再放上去就可以
Tasha: Then just put it on top.
Tasha: 40克好像
Tasha: About 40 grams, I think.
Tasha: 我没记错的话40克
Tasha: If I remember correctly, 40 grams.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Tasha: 然后你可以搅一搅它
Tasha: Then you can stir it.
Lucia: 再搅一搅
Lucia: Stir it again.
Tasha: 对搅拌到看不出一点粉
Tasha: Yeah, until you can't see any powder.
Lucia: 看不出一点粉
Lucia: Can't see any powder.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Hmm, yeah
Alice: 我要开始了
Alice: I'm going to start now
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay
Katrina:  热水烧好了耶
Katrina: The hot water is ready!
Tasha: 你要来抽蛋黄吗
Tasha: Do you want to extract the egg yolk?
Katrina:  嗯我要
Katrina: Yes, I do
Alice: 哎我们家的油呢
Alice: Hey, where's our oil?
Tasha: 呃玉米油行吗
Tasha: Uh, is corn oil okay?
Alice: 随便
Alice: Whatever
Tasha: 玉米油
Tasha: Corn oil
Katrina:  这是后来加了什么
Katrina: What did we add later?
Katrina:  然后变成坨坨了
Katrina: It turned into lumps
Alice: 呃给我一点点点纸好吗
Alice: Uh, can you give me a bit of paper?
Lucia: 呃面粉
Lucia: Uh, flour
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Lucia:啊是面粉吧
Lucia: Ah, it's flour, right?
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes
Lucia: 我们加的
Lucia: We added it
Katrina:  牛奶加油加面
Tasha: OK可以了
Tasha: OK, it's ready
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check
Tasha: 嗯可以了
Tasha: Hmm, it's ready
Tasha: 到你了
Tasha: Your turn
Katrina: 呵呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe
Alice: 我们的葱姜蒜呢
Alice: Where's our scallion, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜
Tasha: Scallion, ginger, and garlic
Alice: 这里边
Alice: Inside here
Lucia: 在调料那一袋里面似乎
Lucia: Seems to be in the seasoning bag
小薇 就在调料里面
Tasha: It's in the seasoning bag
Katrina: 一个方向打就行是吗
Katrina: Just mix in one direction, right?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right
Alice: where where
Alice: Where, where
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh
Alice: 我尊嘟很急
Alice: I'm really in a hurry
Tasha: 把它搅拌为你就融合在一起就行
Tasha: Stir it until everything blends together
Tasha: 你看现在没有融合对吧
Tasha: You see, it's not blended yet, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: Not yet
Alice: 哦有
Alice: Oh, there is
Katrina:  好神奇哦
Katrina: That's so amazing.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: I'm so tired.
Alice: 我们那个现成的蒜呢
Alice: Where's the pre-peeled garlic?
Katrina:  现成的蒜
Katrina: The pre-peeled garlic.
Katrina:  冰箱里嗯
Katrina: In the fridge, yeah.
Alice: 现成的蒜
Alice: The pre-peeled garlic.
Alice: 是不是在那里边
Alice: Is it in there?
Tasha: 现成的蒜
Tasha: The pre-peeled garlic.
Lucia: 看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Tasha: 蒜蒜在这呀
Tasha: The garlic is right here.
Alice: 不是蒜苗蒜就那个白白胖胖的
Alice: Not garlic sprouts, just that white, plump garlic.
Alice: 嗯左左左左左上角
Alice: Yeah, top left, top left.
Alice: 那那那给我一点就行了
Alice: That, just give me a bit of that.
Alice: 拿出来就行
Alice: Just take it out.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: good
Tasha: Good.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: OK然后差不多有时间的话
Tasha: OK, then if we have time...
Tasha: 我们可以把楼上的那个打蛋盆拿下来
Tasha: We can bring down the egg whisking bowl from upstairs.
Lucia: 啊看一眼
Lucia: Ah, take a look.
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Right now?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Lucia: 好像还差几分钟
Lucia: Seems like a few minutes left.
Katrina:  三分钟
Katrina: Three minutes.
Tasha: 三分钟
Tasha: Three minutes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 拿下来吧
Tasha: Let's bring it down.
Lucia: 可以啦 OK
Lucia: Okay, it's fine.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: No problem.
Alice: 没有围裙对吧
Alice: We don't have aprons, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Katrina:  好像没有
Katrina: Seems like we don't.
Alice:就这吧
Alice: Guess we'll manage.
Katrina:  接下来做什么
Katrina: What do we do next?
Tasha:接下来把蛋清
Tasha: Next, we separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 就是刚刚蛋黄和蛋清要分开
Tasha: We need to separate the yolks and egg whites.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 分开之后他们现在先把蛋清打发一下
Tasha: After separating, we whisk the egg whites a bit.
Tasha: 这个部分就先放着
Tasha: Let's set this part aside.
Alice: 顺便帮我剥点蒜
Alice: By the way, help me peel some garlic.
Tasha: 呃不是有专门的蒜 蒜 蒜吗
Tasha: Uh, isn't there a special garlic, garlic, garlic?
Alice: 哎有人 有手吗
Alice: Hey, anyone got a hand?
Katrina:  我帮你不
Katrina: Want me to help you?
Alice: 那个是密密封的
Alice: That one's tightly sealed.
Alice: 我想等到你们那个火锅的时候再用
Alice: I want to use it when you guys have hot pot.
Katrina:  我帮你吧
Katrina: Let me help you.
Tasha: 好这个快结束了
Tasha: Okay, this one's almost done.
Katrina:  就是把它
Katrina: Just...
Alice:: 啊这一点就行
Alice: Ah, that's good enough.
Alice: 有点小不太好拨衣
Alice: It's a bit small, hard to peel.
Lucia: 来喽
Lucia: Here I come.
Katrina:  天呐AI在我这采集数据可杂了
Katrina: Oh my god, the AI is gathering all sorts of data from me.
Katrina:  一会干这一会干那
Katrina: Doing this and that.
Tasha: 然后能把白砂糖拿来吗
Tasha: Can you bring the white sugar?
Lucia: 白砂糖在
Lucia: The white sugar is...
Alice:这这呢
Alice: Here, here.
Alice: 这个这个这个这个里面吧
Alice: This one, this one, inside here.
Lucia: 这里面
Lucia: Inside here.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Katrina:  两个
Katrina: Two.
Alice: 没事我点
Alice: No problem, I'll do it.
Alice: 这蒜太小了不好剥
Alice: This garlic is too small, hard to peel.
Tasha: 还有别的刀吗
Tasha: Are there any other knives?
Alice: 有底下呢
Alice: Yeah, below there.
Lucia: 嗯你看一眼
Lucia: Hmm, take a look.
Lucia: 这样可以吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Tasha:他倒了35克就行
Tasha: Just measure out 35 grams.
Lucia: 倒了35.2吗
Lucia: 35.2 grams?
Katrina:  你看这开水要用吗 烧好了
Katrina: Do we need to use this boiling water? It's ready.
Tasha: 没关系待会用倒
Tasha: It's fine, we'll use it later.
Lucia:然后我把这个白糖放到哎这上面
Lucia: Then I'll put the sugar... right here.
Lucia: 好像已经放满了的样子
Lucia: Looks like it's already full.
Lucia: 管他呢给他挤一点位置出来
Lucia: Whatever, I'll make some space.
Tasha: 你看他现在是蛋清的样子对吧
Tasha: See, it looks like egg whites now, right?
Tasha: 这是35克
Tasha: This is 35 grams.
Tasha: 第一遍只要打出这种细
Tasha: For the first round, just beat it until it's fine.
Alice: 你们是不是明天用火锅就行
Alice: You guys will use the hot pot tomorrow, right?
Katrina:  应该是明天晚上吧
Katrina: Should be tomorrow night.
Alice: 受不了了我要用那个蒜了
Alice: I can't wait, I need to use that garlic now.
Katrina:  要等他回来才
Katrina: We have to wait for him to come back
Tasha: 呃再帮我取5克玉米淀粉吧
Tasha: Uh, can you get me 5 grams of corn starch?
Lucia: 呃15克
Lucia: Uh, 15 grams
Lucia: 5克呃
Lucia: 5 grams, uh
Lucia: 5克
Lucia: 5 grams
Tasha: 用这个用这个取
Tasha: Use this, use this to measure
Lucia: 这个就先拿下来
Lucia: Let's take this down first
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay
Katrina:  还要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Do we need to add lemon too?
Tasha:加过了
Tasha: Already added
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh
Katrina:  为什么要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Why do we need to add lemon?
Tasha: 去腥
Tasha: To get rid of the smell
Katrina:  哦哈哈
Katrina: Oh, haha
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: Is this it?
小薇 嗯对对对5克就行
Tasha: Mm, yes yes yes, 5 grams is enough
Tasha: 然后第二遍是这个状态就行
Tasha: Then the second time, it should be in this state
Lucia: 哇嗯
Lucia: Wow, mm
Tasha: 然后最后一遍
Tasha: Then the final time
Lucia: 好神奇蛋清竟然会打成这样
Lucia: It's amazing that egg whites can be whipped like this
Lucia: 等一下这个要把它再清理一下吗
Lucia: Wait, do we need to clean this again?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Tasha: 5克
Tasha: 5 grams
Tasha: 可以可以好给我吧
Tasha: Okay, okay, give it to me
Alice: 好我们是没有汤勺
Alice: Okay, we don't have a ladle
Alice: 应该有吧
Alice: There should be one
Alice: 没有汤勺
Alice: No ladle
Alice: 在后面
Alice: It's in the back
Lucia: 汤勺我好像也没看见
Lucia: I don't think I've seen the ladle either
Lucia: 看他们这有没有
Lucia: Let's see if they have one
Lucia: 是卖的哈哈哈
Lucia: They might be selling it, haha
Lucia: 这样先晃一下吧
Lucia: Let's shake it a bit first
Tasha: 希望他不会拒绝吧
Tasha: Hope he won't refuse
Katrina:  爱上了打蛋
Katrina: Fell in love with egg beating
Katrina:
Tasha: 打发成这样子能提起来
Tasha: Beat it until it can hold its shape
Tasha: 然后他不会
Tasha: Then it won't
Tasha: 他你看他这个有个尖尖
Tasha: Look, there's a peak
Tasha: 他不会掉下来就说明就打完了
Tasha: If it doesn't fall, it means it's done
Alice: 一步是要把水锅里的水给蒸发一下
Alice: First step is to evaporate the water in the pot.
Alice: 不然他会怎么样
Alice: Otherwise, what will happen?
Tasha: 就是一个废气
Tasha: It'll just be a waste.
Alice: 他会啪啦啪啦的
Alice: It'll start splattering everywhere.
Alice: 就是水跟油不香
Alice: Water and oil don't mix well.
Alice: 他们不是好朋友
Alice: They're not friends.
Alice: 他们会打架
Alice: They'll fight.
Alice: 居然是玉米油
Alice: It's actually corn oil.
Katrina:  我们俩特别像学生
Katrina: We look like students.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  这老师在干什么
Katrina: What's the teacher doing?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 然后有种接受培训的感觉
Lucia: Feels like we're getting trained.
Katrina:  我们在新东方啊
Katrina: We're at New Oriental, huh?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 把这个分三次划进去
Tasha: Divide this into three parts.
Tasha: 第一遍的话就只有分三遍刮
Tasha: The first time, you only scrape in three parts.
Tasha: 他才会充分融合
Tasha: Only then will it fully blend.
Tasha: 第一遍的话他不是会很充分
Tasha: The first time, it won't fully blend.
Tasha: 你可能觉得他充分了
Tasha: You might think it’s blended.
Tasha: 但其实没那么充分
Tasha: But actually, it's not.
Katrina:  这个白色的就是刚刚蛋清加了什么的
Katrina: This white stuff is egg white mixed with something, right?
Tasha: 蛋清加了糖啊
Tasha: Egg white mixed with sugar.
Katrina:  蛋清加了糖就变成这样了对
Katrina: Egg white mixed with sugar becomes this, right?
Katrina:  蛋清刚刚不是液体吗
Katrina: Wasn't the egg white liquid?
Katrina:  现在怎么变成橡皮体
Katrina: How did it become rubbery?
Katrina:  嗯因为那个机器打就是啊
Katrina: Hmm, because the machine whipped it.
Katrina:  然后他就会起泡
Katrina: Then it started foaming.
Lucia: 对好神奇的哦 哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, it's amazing. Hahaha.
Katrina:  amazing
Katrina: Amazing.
Katrina:  蛋清加了蛋清
Katrina: Egg white mixed with egg white.
Tasha: 然后加第二次进去
Tasha: Then add the second part.
Alice: 其实我放错顺序
Alice: Actually, I did it in the wrong order.
Alice: 我应该先放皮蛋的
Alice: I should've added the century egg first.
Tasha: 嗯我觉得应该先把烤箱预热
Tasha: Yeah, I think we should preheat the oven first.
Lucia: 要预热一下吗
Lucia: Should we preheat it?
Lucia: 等一下
Lucia: Wait a second.
Tasha: 热水在吗
Tasha: Is the hot water ready?
Tasha: 在
Tasha: It's ready.
Tasha: 有点水没关系哦
Tasha: A little water is okay.
Lucia: 要擦一下吗
Lucia: Do you want to wipe it?
Tasha: 哦可以擦一下
Tasha: Oh, you can wipe it.
Tasha: 哦谢谢
Tasha: Oh, thanks.
Tasha: 哦对然后我们把这个第二个
Tasha: Oh right, and then we put this second...
Alice: 粘锅了
Alice: It's sticking to the pan.
Alice: 哦啊
Alice: Oh, ah.
Tasha: 预热一下的
Tasha: Preheat it a bit.
Tasha: 话烤箱里的温度更好
Tasha: The temperature in the oven is better.
Lucia: OK啊边上这个也擦一下吧
Lucia: Okay, let's wipe this part too.
Tasha: 看其实你以为很融合
Tasha: Look, you think it's well mixed.
Tasha: 但其实还是没那么融合
Tasha: But actually, it's not that well mixed.
Tasha: 所以就是要分三遍
Tasha: So, you need to do it in three batches.
Lucia:要分次
Lucia: In batches.
Tasha: 对然后你可以把纸杯蛋糕放上去
Tasha: Yes, then you can put the cupcakes on top.
Lucia: 放到这个
Lucia: Put them here?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia:托盘上
Lucia: On the tray?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  然后排起开烤
Katrina: Then line them up and start baking.
Tasha: 这就是我们的蛋糕胚部分就完成了
Tasha: So that's the basic part of our cake done.
Katrina:  哦然后就把它舀进去就好了
Katrina: Oh, then just scoop it in.
Lucia:哦原来蛋糕胚是这样做的
Lucia: Oh, so that's how you make the cake base.
Lucia: 6个我们这个需要几个
Lucia: We need six, how many do we need?
Katrina:  大概能装多少个
Katrina: How many can this make?
Tasha: 呃这个
Tasha: Uh, this...
Tasha: 哈哈哈 好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Katrina: 装了再说吧
Katrina: Just fill them up first.
Tasha: 就就这样放着吧
Tasha: Just leave it like that.
Lucia: 行呃
Lucia: Alright, uh...
Tasha: 不太能确定
Tasha: Not really sure.
Lucia: 没事装完要是不够
Lucia: It's okay, if it's not enough...
Lucia: 我们再拿出几个杯子
Lucia: We can get more cups.
Tasha: 可以放到这个里面
Tasha: You can put it in here.
Tasha: 因为这个有个嘴
Tasha: Because this has a spout.
Tasha: 他好倒啊
Tasha: It's easier to pour.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 所以这个杯子他既可以倒嘴
Tasha: So this cup can both pour easily...
Tasha: 然后呢他还有容容量
Tasha: And it also has capacity.
Katrina:  这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Tasha: 呃叫鸟嘴杯
Tasha: Uh, it's called a spout cup.
Tasha: 鸟嘴杯只要做烘焙都会买的
Tasha: Anyone who does baking will buy a spout cup.
Tasha: 好了然后就就倒就行了
Tasha: Alright, then just pour it in.
Tasha: 大家可以都试试
Tasha: Everyone can give it a try.
Tasha: 倒到差不多这里
Tasha: Pour it to about here.
Tasha: 因为它会膨膨胀起来嘛
Tasha: Because it will expand.
Lucia: 哦嗯
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 咦你先来啊
Lucia: Oh, you go first.
Katrina:  好你先打样
Katrina: Alright, you show us.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我们学习一下如何倒
Lucia: Let's learn how to pour it.
Katrina:  啊差不多这么多就行啊
Katrina: Ah, about this much should be enough.
Lucia: 来慢慢了解啊
Lucia: Let's take it slow and understand.
Lucia: 我试一下谢谢
Lucia: Let me try, thanks.
Tasha: 好了好
Tasha: Alright, good.
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Tasha: 挪果断的挪没关系哈哈
Tasha: Move decisively, it's okay, haha.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Katrina:  可以好像可以再倒一点什么
Katrina: You can probably pour a bit more, right?
Lucia: 姐妹你来
Lucia: Sis, you go.
Lucia: 他好像滴出来了一点点
Lucia: It seems like a bit is dripping out.
Tasha:没关系没关系
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 在边上没事吧
Lucia: It's on the side, it's fine right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 继续倒吧
Tasha: Keep pouring.
Lucia: 对可以再倒一点
Lucia: Yes, you can pour a bit more.
Lucia: 感觉好像没有特别多
Lucia: It feels like there's not enough.
Katrina:  差不多了
Katrina: That's about right.
Katrina:  好，给我吧
Katrina: Okay, give it to me.
Lucia: 是不是挨近一点
Lucia: Should it be closer?
Tasha: 瓜瓜还能再来一杯
Tasha: Gua gua can have another cup.
Lucia: 呃再放一个杯子啊
Lucia: Uh, place another cup?
Katrina:  不用啊
Katrina: No need.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: OK最后我一共烤了10个嗯哼
Tasha: OK, I baked a total of 10, mm-hmm.
Tasha: 然后我们送入烤箱就可以
Tasha: Then we can put them in the oven.
Lucia: 要按一下哪里
Lucia: Where do you press?
Lucia: 哦那让他
Lucia: Oh, let him do it.
Lucia: 那个表为什么又倒了
Lucia: Why did the timer reset?
Tasha: 哦你看它这温度其实不准
Tasha: Oh, you see, the temperature here isn't accurate.
Tasha: 烤箱温度显示它已经
Tasha: The oven temperature shows it has already...
Katrina:  哇好可爱
Katrina: Wow, so cute!
Alice: 感觉好像坏掉了
Alice: It feels like it's broken.
Alice: 算了不放它
Alice: Never mind, don't put it in.
Katrina:  这大概烤多久啊
Katrina: How long does this bake for?
Tasha: 呃50分钟
Tasha: Uh, 50 minutes.
Tasha: 正好吃饭吃完饭吧
Tasha: Just in time to eat, after we finish eating.
Tasha: 行了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 第一次是口烤20分钟
Tasha: The first time is to bake for 20 minutes.
Katrina:  啊分分次的
Katrina: Oh, in multiple rounds.
Tasha: 对他先低温烤熟
Tasha: Yes, bake it at low temperature first.
Tasha: 然后高温上色啊
Tasha: Then increase the temperature to color it.
Katrina:  好好玩
Katrina: So fun!
Tasha: 他如果盯了之后
Tasha: After it beeps...
Tasha: 我如果不在的话就是他这个时间到了
Tasha: If I'm not here, the time will be up.
Tasha: 20分钟就到了
Tasha: It'll be 20 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯然后你把这个上火调成130
Tasha: Then, set the top heat to 130.
Tasha: 下火也调成130
Tasha: And the bottom heat also to 130.
Tasha: 再打30分钟
Tasha: Bake for another 30 minutes.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Katrina:  13013030
Tasha: yes然后我们要把残垃圾清理掉
Tasha: Yes, then we need to clean up the trash.
Tasha: 尤其是这个盆
Tasha: Especially this bowl.
Tasha: 因为等会咱们还得再打奶油
Tasha: Because we'll need it to whip the cream later.
Tasha: 也是用它的
Tasha: We'll use it again.
Lucia: OK OK这些这些纸就先先扔了吧
Lucia: OK, OK, let's throw away these papers first.
Tasha: 对全部都扔掉
Tasha: Yes, throw them all away.
Tasha: 这个是洗一下
Tasha: This one needs to be washed.
Tasha: 然后全部都洗
Tasha: Then wash everything.
Tasha: 然后擦干
Tasha: And dry them.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Lucia: 这个哎
Lucia: This, hey...
Lucia: 那我就把这个菜先拿出来
Lucia: I'll take these dishes out first.
Lucia: 菜放这就会
Lucia: Put the dishes here.
Lucia: 嗯这边水倒掉一点吧
Lucia: Hmm, pour out some of this water.
Tasha: 对我把垃圾收一下
Tasha: Yes, I'll collect the trash.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Tasha: 这些都是要洗的
Tasha: All of these need to be washed.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Alice: 白菜呢嗯
Alice: Where's the cabbage? Hmm...
Lucia: 在这里我害怕洗那个什么
Lucia: I’m scared to wash that thing here.
Lucia: 洗到里面我就把它拿出来了
Lucia: When I washed it, I just took it out.
Alice: 涮一下这个
Alice: Rinse this one.
Lucia: 呃咱这应该有抹布吧
Lucia: Uh, we should have a cloth here, right?
Tasha: 有吧
Tasha: Probably.
Lucia: 没有的话
Lucia: If not...
Lucia: 哎呀那个那个那个海绵有点脏
Lucia: Oh, that sponge is a bit dirty.
Lucia: 不是很想用啊
Lucia: I don't really want to use it.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: There's another one here.
Lucia: 这给他扔过去哎
Lucia: Let's just throw this one over there.
Katrina:  见你有种似曾相识的感觉喔哦耶
Katrina: Meeting you feels so familiar, oh yeah.
Katrina: 遇见你有种似曾相识的感觉哦呜
Katrina: Meeting you feels so familiar, oh woo.
Katrina:  遇见你有一种似曾相识的感觉喔哦耶
Katrina: Meeting you feels so familiar, oh yeah.
Katrina:  咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Lucia: 我们的外卖到了
Lucia: Our delivery is here.
Jake: 哦强势保温
Jake: Oh, keep it warm with a strong hold.
Lucia: 所以地上就放了一个火炉保温
Lucia: So they put a stove on the floor to keep it warm.
Jake: 对那这个没有
Jake: Yeah, but this one doesn't have...
Jake: 有个电饭锅
Jake: There's a rice cooker.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 哦我要买东西
Katrina: Oh, I need to buy something.
Katrina: 哦不和液我买了
Katrina: Oh no, I already bought it.
Katrina:  他今天中午说那个货币
Katrina: He mentioned that currency at noon today.
Katrina:  这个货币可不可以用这种贴纸来代替
Katrina: Can we use these stickers as currency?
Katrina:  因为这贴纸想要卖
Katrina: Because I want to sell these stickers.
Katrina:  不知道贴哪
Katrina: Don't know where to stick them.
Katrina:  贴了会留痕
Katrina: They might leave marks.
Katrina:  然后你那个货币的话
Katrina: And then with your currency...
Katrina:  那你就得买游戏币
Katrina: You'd have to buy game coins.
Katrina:  买了也没啥用
Katrina: Buying them is useless.
Lucia: 是可以节约一些日寸
Lucia: It can save some space.
Lucia: 而且贴纸留着
Lucia: And keep the stickers.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: That's good.
Katrina: 贴纸时时刻刻提醒他们
Katrina: Stickers constantly remind them.
Katrina:  参加过世界地球日的
Katrina: That they participated in Earth Day.
Katrina:  那就把这个当货币吧
Katrina: Let's just use these as currency.
Katrina: 嗯还可以用一下
Katrina: Hmm, it might work.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  把所有的理下来脑子也就轻松了
Katrina: Once you sort everything out, your mind will be at ease.
Katrina:  这也便宜
Katrina: This is cheap too.
Alice: 但是这个颜色不知道为什么
Alice: But this color, I don't know why...
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it as milky white?
Katrina: 可以呀
Katrina: Sure.
Alice: 不知道为什么他好黑
Alice: I don't know why it's so black.
Alice: 我好难受
Alice: I feel so uncomfortable.
Alice: 因为皮蛋原因吧
Alice: Maybe because of the century egg.
Alice: 不是就是之前是白的不知道为什么
Alice: No, it was white before, I don't know why...
Alice: 这次啊乌漆嘛黑的
Alice: This time it's all dark.
Alice: 可能没放牛奶或者怎样
Alice: Maybe they didn't add milk or something.
Alice: 你少盛一点吧
Alice: Take a little less.
Alice:: 害怕你受不了
Alice: I'm afraid you can't handle it.
Katrina:  哦还放牛奶
Katrina: Oh, they add milk?
Alice: 哎这个颜色好害怕呀
Alice: Ah, this color is scary.
Katrina:  没关系
Katrina: It's okay.
Lucia: 嗯我这很害怕
Lucia: Hmm, I'm really scared.
Katrina:  有勺吗
Katrina: Do we have a spoon?
Katrina:  这就像皮蛋瘦肉粥一样
Katrina: This is just like century egg and lean pork congee.
Katrina:  有勺吗哇
Alice: 有筷子 用筷子
Alice: There are chopsticks, use the chopsticks.
Katrina:  那就用那个
Katrina: Then use those.
Katrina:  上次谁用的一次性书
Katrina: Who used the disposable ones last time?
Tasha: 今天中午剩下的那些一次性
Tasha: The leftover disposable ones from lunch today.
Katrina:  我去看一下
Katrina: I'll go check.
Katrina: 昨天那个一次性那个
Katrina: The disposable ones from yesterday.
Katrina:  那个筷子
Katrina: The chopsticks.
Katrina:  因为没有勺子
Katrina: Because there are no spoons.
Katrina:  他做的
Katrina: He made it.
Jake: 有勺子，有肯德基留下的勺子
Jake: There are spoons, KFC left some spoons.
Katrina:  哦在这在这
Katrina: Oh, here they are.
Katrina:  嗯我决定就是今天
Katrina: Hmm, I've decided it's today.
Katrina:  呃修硕不是说那个货币嘛
Katrina: Uh, Shure mentioned the currency thing.
Katrina:  嗯货币
Katrina: Hmm, currency.
Katrina:  我就打算能不能用那个
Katrina: I was thinking if we could use that.
Katrina:  我给你看那个贴纸他充当
Katrina: Let me show you the stickers, they can stand in.
Katrina:  因为贴纸他确实没法什么贴
Katrina: Because the stickers can't really stick to anything.
Katrina:  然后你买那货币的话
Katrina: And if you buy the currency.
Katrina:  要买游戏币也没啥用对吧
Katrina: Buying game tokens is useless, right?
Katrina:  那样的话
Katrina: So...
Katrina:  时时刻刻提醒他们
Katrina: It constantly reminds them.
Katrina:  参加过世界地球日的活动
Katrina: Have you ever participated in Earth Day activities?
Katrina: : 贴纸还便宜
Katrina: The stickers were cheap too.
Katrina:  拿这个勺试试
Katrina: Try this spoon.
Katrina:  尝一下
Katrina: Taste it.
Tasha:结束了
Tasha: It's over.
Tasha: 开会啊不是结束了
Tasha: The meeting, not the end.
Katrina:  嗯味道挺好的
Katrina: Hmm, it tastes pretty good.
Tasha: 呃没有好喝吗
Tasha: Uh, isn't it tasty?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice: 好这颜色
Alice: This color looks good.
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it being milky white?
Tasha: 啊怎么会变成这个颜色
Tasha: Ah, how did it turn this color?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我想先尝尝咸淡
Tasha: I want to taste the saltiness first.
Alice: 你拿直接勺吧
Alice: Just use the spoon directly.
Alice: 有没有别的
Alice: Is there anything else?
Tasha: 嗯我觉得可以
Tasha: Hmm, I think it's okay.
Alice: 咸吗
Alice: Is it salty?
Tasha: 我觉得可以再加一点点盐
Tasha: I think it could use a little more salt.
Alice: 再加点盐
Alice: Add more salt.
Katrina:  有点咸其实
Katrina: It's actually a bit salty.
Tasha: 嗯那可能我喝的有点少吧
Tasha: Hmm, maybe I didn't drink enough.
Alice: 有点咸还有点甜
Alice: It's a bit salty and a bit sweet.
Katrina:  咸，不是我吃正好不用加盐了我的意思是
Katrina: Salty, I meant it's just right for me, no need for more salt.
Alice: 你要加盐吗
Alice: Do you want to add salt?
Tasha: 呃我不加了
Tasha: Uh, no more for me.
Tasha: 呃给我也来一碗
Tasha: Uh, give me a bowl too.
Alice: 你自己来点吧
Alice: Serve yourself.
Tasha: 呃不了不了你帮我加一碗就行了
Tasha: Uh, no, no, you help me with a bowl.
Tasha: 为什么大家不吃饭
Tasha: Why isn't everyone eating?
Alice: 还没到吧
Alice: Not yet, I guess.
Tasha: 哎刚刚饭不是到了吗
Tasha: Hey, wasn't the food just delivered?
Katrina:  把它因为我我也不知道
Katrina: Because, I don't know either.
Katrina:  哈哈开玩笑的
Katrina: Haha, just kidding.
Alice: 给 你饿了吗
Alice: Here, are you hungry?
Tasha: 多吗嗯你倒入一点
Tasha: Is it too much? Hmm, pour a little.
Tasha: 大家一人有一碗吗
Tasha: Does everyone have a bowl?
Alice: 足足的
Alice: Plenty for everyone.
Tasha: 好 我问一下   饭呢
Tasha: Okay, let me ask, where's the food?
Katrina: 这还要放胡椒粉吗
Katrina: Should we add pepper to this?
Tasha: 好了大家都下来吃饭了
Tasha: Okay, everyone come down to eat.
Tasha: 不过为什么不在上面吃呢
Tasha: But why aren't we eating upstairs?
Lucia: 因为土豆里下面好像比上面多一点
Lucia: Because it seems like there are more potatoes down here than upstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈走
Tasha: Hahaha, let's go.
Tasha: 你要不要把那个锅拿上去
Tasha: Do you want to take that pot upstairs?
Tasha: 嗯把这碗汤汤端上去
Tasha: Yeah, take this bowl of soup upstairs.
Tasha: 对因为不是在上面吃饭吗
Tasha: Yeah, because we're eating upstairs, right?
Jake: 好我先端上去
Jake: Okay, I'll take it up first.
Alice: 哎把它想象成
Alice: Hey, imagine it...
Alice: 奶白色的话会不会好点
Alice: If it were milky white, would it be better?
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: I can't stand it.
Alice: 这乌漆嘛黑的好难过
Alice: This dark color is so depressing.
Tasha: 换个温度
Tasha: Change the temperature.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 端上去吗
Tasha: Should I take it up?
Tasha: 嗯在楼上吃晚饭
Tasha: Yeah, having dinner upstairs.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: Okay.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Katrina:  这是我拿了一勺
Katrina: I took a scoop of this.
Katrina:  我拿这个吧
Katrina: I'll take this one.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 我要给自己倒一杯橙汁
Tasha: I'm going to pour myself a glass of orange juice.
Katrina:  这谁的杯子
Katrina: Whose cup is this?
Katrina:  喝了果粒
Katrina: It has pulp in it.
Katrina:  哼哼哼哼哼哼
Katrina: 哇这么大一盘
Katrina: Wow, such a big plate.
Katrina: 可以给我一张纸吗
Katrina: Can I have a napkin?
Katrina: 可以给我拿一张纸吗
Katrina: Can you get me a napkin?
Katrina:  这是汤吗
Katrina: Is this soup?
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 我们有点汤吗
Tasha: Do we have some soup?
Lucia: 我们没点汤
Lucia: We didn't order soup.
Katrina:  这是番茄牛腩吗
Katrina: Is this tomato beef brisket?
Tasha: 我靠这是番茄牛腩
Tasha: Damn, this is tomato beef brisket.
Lucia: 用汤看起来好像番茄汤啊
Lucia: It looks like tomato soup with the broth.
Tasha: 有备注不要香菜吗
Tasha: Did we note no cilantro?
Alice: 哎最后谁下单的啊
Alice: Hey, who placed the order in the end?